vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir deux ans que
la guerre au tigré a commenté elle est
pour elle oppose le pouvoir central
éthiopien au Rebel tigreen deux ans mais
aucun bilan officiel on parle de
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
victimes nous font le point avec notre
correspondant régional qui couvre
l'actualité depuis les tous premiers
jours
nous reviendrons sur l'affaire
Omar Labidi ce jeune Tunisien mort il y
a 4 ans noyé dans une rivière en tentant
d'échapper à des agents de police le
verdict a été rendu 12 policiers
condamnés à deux ans de prison ferme une
condamnation insuffisante pour les
familles nous les entendons
et ce soir on reçoit une brillante
photojournaliste multiprimée brésilienne
installé à Paris depuis 13 ans qui
s'intéresse aux questions d'identité et
elle nous présente un livre photo qui
s'appelle first generation consacré aux
Françaises originaire d'Afrique de
l'Ouest des femmes noires qu'elle révèle
au monde d'une façon unique Carolina
arène S et notre invité du journal de
l'Afrique
deux ans que les forces gouvernementales
éthiopienne affrontent les rebelles du
Tigré à ce jour impossible de donner un
bilan exact des victimes certaines
estimations parlent de centaines de
milliers de morts dont de très nombreux
civils et de nombreux crimes de guerre
notre correspondant régional Bastien
renouilles qui couvre le conflit depuis
les tous premiers jours revient sur la
situation de la population tigrée
deux ans jour pour jour après le début
de la garantie grille il est extrêmement
difficile de parler avec certitude de ce
qu'il se passe sur place le gouvernement
éthiopien n'autorise pas les
journalistes à se rendre dans la région
du Tigré nous n'avons pas pu obtenir
d'autorisation et les agences
humanitaires de l'ONU les ONG ne peuvent
pas non plus se déplacer dans cette
région à cause des risques inhérents au
conflit en cours alors on ne sait pas
exactement quelle est la situation sur
place que je peux vous dire avec
certitude c'est que au moins 90% de la
population tigraine plus de 5 millions
de personnes à besoin d'urgence d'aide
humanitaire qu'il s'agisse de soins
médicaux ou d'aide alimentaire et la
nourriture c'est vraiment ce qui manque
le plus en ce moment dans la région du
Tigré les récoltes ont été détruites
depuis deux ans il n'y a plus de
nourriture qui arrive dans cette région
alors la population a faim et a besoin
d'urgence de nourriture une nourriture
qui pourrait arriver durant les
prochains jours si l'accès est possible
suite à la signature des accords de
ccfeu cette semaine en Afrique du Sud la
population à cet espoir dans la région
du tigre il puisse enfin avoir un petit
peu de nourriture l'espoir aussi du côté
des réfugiés tigrés en dessous dans ils
sont plus de 70 000 à vivre dans des
conditions misérables à proximité de la
frontière et donc ils espèrent pouvoir
rentrer chez eux si ce cesser le feu
tiens s'il y a réellement des accords de
paix qui sont signés mais des cesser le
feu il y en a déjà eu un dans le passé
et il n'a pas tenu et puis il y a aussi
les troupeseries qui sont présentes au
nord du tigree qui ont envahi cette
région qui sont toujours sur place
vont-elles rentrer dans leur pays ou pas
et bien impossible de le savoir pour
l'heure or si elles sont toujours
présentes il sera extrêmement compliqué
pour les populations de rentrer chez
elle il sera aussi compliqué pour les
ONG d'accéder à toutes ces populations
deux ans de prison ferme c'est la
condamnation dans une affaire
emblématique en Tunisie les 12 policiers
ont été reconnus coupables de missiles
involontaire de Omar Labidi ce jeune
homme est mort il y a 4 ans noyé dans
une rivière en tentant d'échapper à des
agents de police pour la famille la
condamnation prononcée n'est pas
suffisante lilia Blaise
juste après l'annonce du verdict la
famille d'Omar Labidi ainsi que son
comité de défense sont annoncé vouloir
interjeter en appel la décision
judiciaire pour le comité de défense et
les avocats qui ont dénoncé une
mascarade de justice ce jeudi il s'agit
d'une peine insuffisante les deux ans
d'emprisonnement pour homicide
involontaire auquel ont été condamnés 12
agents de police impliqués dans
l'affaire les avocats avaient également
demandé à ce que le motif d'accusation
de non-assistance à personne en danger
punie de jusqu'à 5 ans d'emprisonnement
soit également retenu contre les
policiers dans cette affaire en effet il
y a quatre ans alors Comar Labidi
sortait d'un match de foot et tenté
d'échapper à une patrouille de police
après des bagarres entre supporters des
témoins avaient entendu les policiers
crier aux jeunes juste avant qu'ils ne
soient forcés de sauter dans l'oued pour
leur échapper ils avaient entendu les
policiers criaient aux jeunes apprend à
nager alors que celui-ci leur avait
spécifiquement dit qu'il ne pas nager
une campagne de mobilisation sous ce
hashtag avait démarré et avait lutté
pendant quatre ans contre l'impunité des
policiers cette affaire est en effet
emblématique en Tunisie des violations
policières qui traînent souvent en
justice pour les défenseurs des droits
humains beaucoup de cas semblables à
celui d'Omar Labidi sont aujourd'hui
encore sous enquête ou dans des procès
la Ligue tunisienne des droits de
l'homme a recensé près d'une vingtaine
de cas de jeunes tunisiens morts dans
des circonstances suspectes après des
altercations avec la police et tout au
long du mois d'octobre l'affaire d'Omar
Labidi mais aussi d'autres affaires
avaient mobilisé les jeunes des
quartiers populaires et la société
civile dans une série de manifestations
en RD Congo que s'est-il passé au
concert de l'artiste Fally UPA le flou
persiste presque une semaine après le
concert les autorités congolaises ont
publié une liste de 11 spectateurs dont
deux policiers morts dans une bousculade
au stade des Martyrs Kinshasa police et
organisateur se rejettent les
responsabilités en attendant les
familles attendent les corps de leurs
enfants pour faire leur deuil reportage
à Kinshasa d'Aurélie bazarra qui
Bangoura
des larmes et des pleurs une famille
inconsolable dans cette banlieue de
Kinshasa tous pris pour dolvabo Lely à
23 ans le jeune homme serait mort au
concert de Fally Ipupa samedi dernier
n'a pas mon cœur saigne je souffre
beaucoup la douleur est très fort il est
parti au concert et à 23 ans
on avait encore besoin de l'unité 6
jours après le drame la famille attend
qu'on lui remette le corps de son fils
conservé par les autorités pour les
besoins de l'enquête
avant de ma sœur est partie pour rien on
ne sait pas pourquoi qu'est-ce que
c'était passé il va vous donner des
explications qu'est-ce que c'est passé
dans le vabolini n'est pas le seul à
être décédé après le concert du 29
octobre 10 autres personnes dont deux
policiers sont mortes ce soir-là selon
le gouvernement les autorités accusent
les organisateurs d'avoir surchargé le
stade 120000 personnes y étaient
présentes selon la police alors que la
capacité maximum est de 80 000 places de
leur côté les organisateurs accusent les
agents de la police d'avoir laissé
entrer des fans sans billets contre une
petite somme d'argent pour cette
association une enquête indépendante
doit être ouverte faut pas qu'il y ait
de
je dirais des faux fouillant les
autorités ne doivent pas se dédouaner
qu'on puisse tout simplement exprimer
les organisateurs mais je crois qu'il y
a des autorités qui doivent accepter
aussi de partager la responsabilité par
rapport à ce qui est arrivé parce que
aucun événement ne s'organise dans cette
ville sans le consentement des autorités
et sans l'accompagnement de la Police
nationale congolaise la police devrait
rendre public les conclusions de son
enquête dans les prochains jours le
gouvernement a déjà annoncé qu'un
dossier judiciaire a été ouvert contre
les organisateurs
notre invité de ce soir est une
brillante photographe journaliste né au
Brésil elle vit habite en France depuis
13 ans son regard questionne à travers
les images les identités multiples comme
celle des Françaises noires qu'elle a
rencontré dont elle retrace le parcours
dans un ouvrage magnifique first
generation Carolina arenes merci d'être
avec nous dans notre invité du journal
de l'Afrique mais c'est Fatima attendais
cette invitation spéciale alors donc
nous dites nous d'abord comment est né
ce projet il y a 8 ans pourquoi avoir
choisi un tel projet alors j'étais je
venais d'arriver en France et toute
quelle questionnement d'identité mis à
douche toujours toucher énormément
la mixité au Brésil elle est tellement
ancrée dans notre relation et dans notre
identité nationale avec toutes ces
problèmes qui vient avec et ça m'y a
donné beaucoup la curiosité de savoir
comment ça se passait en Europe et cette
mixité dans une monde mondialisé pense
colonial en fait mais alors pourquoi les
femmes précisément et pas les hommes
noirs c'est une bonne question les
femmes les hommes on a déjà
en tant qu'étrangère on a déjà une sorte
de curiosité et
curiosité une formation sur leur
identité afro française si on peut le
dire
à partir de cinéma à partir de le sport
à partir de RIP propre il est femme
française à la zone place des modèles
international qui est très forte et donc
je me demandais exactement comment
c'était pour les femmes de première
génération de vivre cette identité
française il construit cette
biculturelle
sans avoir en sorte de reconnaissance au
milieu d'une identité très présente qui
a la femme parisienne française
mondialement donc ça veut dire des
femmes noires venant d'Afrique de
l'Ouest qui sont une nuit s'installer de
la PS que vous appelez first generation
c'est celle qui sont arrivées de la
première génération et en particulier
c'est l'arrivée dans les années 70 c'est
ça c'est que j'appelle
qui sont nées des parents immigrés de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest et qui sont nés à
partir de regroupe de la loi de
regroupement familial c'est-à-dire que à
partir du moment le gouvernement a
permis aux hommes qui sont venus à un
travail en France des ramener leur
famille et les enfants nés en France ce
sont les premières citoyens
franco-africains mais citoyen en France
donc c'est la première génération à
partir et comment ils ont été
sélectionnés dites nous c'est quoi leur
points communs finalement alors moi
j'étais assez enquête de comment ramener
ses regards vers la France je ne voulais
pas qu'on puisse
construire une histoire et qui qui cette
histoire puisse être vu d'une façon à
regarder les femmes noires françaises de
façon communautaire donc pour en général
en photo documentaire on choisit deux
trois personnages et là j'ai vraiment
mélangé des femmes qui sont des origines
différentes de l'Afrique de l'Ouest et
des Sénégalaises cote de voir congolaise
il togolaise même des entre des familles
mixtes pour qu'on puisse voir exactement
cette mélange qui a en France
aujourd'hui donc le choix c'était fait
d'une façon à trouver des femmes qui
sont déjà ancrées et qui sont déjà
positionnés dans une sorte de de travail
scolarité de 13 très très à l'aise dans
leur quotidien
des femmes intégrées alors j'aimerais
qu'on choisisse peut-être une parce que
évidemment j'invite nos spectateurs à se
procurer cet ouvrage et puis regarder
les différents personnages mais s'il
fallait en choisir qu'une il y en a une
qui interpelle et qui est sur la une
photo voilà qu'on voit à l'image à
gauche c'est ça c'est sa famille qu'on
voit et c'est Fatoumata Koné alors
évidemment il n'y a aucun lien avec moi
c'est un hasard
mais pourquoi pas les nous de Fatoumata
connu justement qu'est-ce qui vous a
intéressé dans son histoire et que vous
racontez justement dans le livre parce
que je précise aussi qu'il y a des
textes qui racontent les textes sont
très importants d'ailleurs mais en
parlant de fatma en temps elle est
apparu assez tardivement dans le projet
mais elle a rapporté une histoire assez
spéciale parce que Fatoumata elle a est
la présidente de l'Europe les Verts
Écologie Les Verts
au Conseil de Paris et Fatma devient
d'une famille dénigrer dont le père a
été ébore de Paris donc elle a
tracé un destin et une présence et une
représentativité dans la dans la
politique et dans l'histoire française
hier une histoire qui ramène et qui
consolide cette pose immigration d'une
façon assez assez forte donc il y a
aussi je trouve que c'est extrêmement
important
ces archives qui allaient apporté comme
celui-là de la couverture qu'on voit
exactement la sa maman qui arrive avec
les enfants qui sont qui viennent de
naître en France et qui marque cette ces
moments de nouvelles génération en
France et on voit la photo où justement
avec les archives il y a cette carte que
vous montrez donc la carte d'éboueur de
son père et la carte à elle finalement à
la mairie de Paris où elle a une place
d'officielle
on éclosion il est en présence déjà dans
la dans la société française qui est
extrêmement forte et qu'on peut pas nier
parce que cette génération c'est qu'il y
a très importante à dire c'est qui c'est
l'émigration la génération des un enfant
dé immigrés ont sont en train de
construire leur identité biculturelle en
pleine conscience on choisissant
qu'est-ce qui ça va aller de la culture
française qu'est ce que ça va rester
dans la culture africaine et il a une
génération prochaine ça sera
complètement différente parce que les
enfants nés de cette première génération
vont avoir déjà toutes les supports et
de l'intégration des parents absolument
et alors c'est évidemment ça résonne
forcément avec l'actualité merci
beaucoup Carolina rentes d'être venu sur
ce plateau du journaliste et c'est ainsi
que nous refermons cette édition du
journal l'Afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis et un particulier à Naïm
et à sa sœur qui sont venus depuis
Boulogne pour nous voir merci
[Musique]